la muerte de Jade era tan bajo custodia
israelí mientras realizaba una huelga de
hambre ha tocado una fibra sensible
entre los palestinos adnan considerado
un líder político de las hijas islámicas
Palestina y esta vez es detenido bajo
acusaciones de pertenecer a un grupo
terrorista e incitar a la violencia
falleció por el deterioro de su estado
de salud luego de pasar 86 días sin
ingerir comida ni líquidos según el
servicio de prisiones israelí atland de
45 años se negó a recibir asistencia
médica hasta su último momento en la
cárcel ni nitsan de rambla pero su
familia y su abogado afirman que las
autoridades israelíesen negaron el
pedido de que fuera trasladado a un
hospital para que su condición fuera
monitoreada correctamente
arrestado 12 veces para un total de ocho
años en prisión se había realizado otras
cuatro huelgas de hambre y en 2012 había
inspirado que casi dos mil prisioneros
siguieran esa medida este tipo de
protesta es usada por los presos
palestinos como denuncia contra
encarcelamientos que consideran injustos
Poco después de conocerse su muerte tres
cohetes fueron lanzados desde casa a
Israel activando las sirenas Aunque
cayeron en espacios abiertos también se
observa una huelga general en casas y
Jordania en Jerusalén este así como
algunas movilizaciones en arraba Ciudad
natal de andan en el norte de Jordania
ocupada se reunieron unas 200 personas y
su viuda pidió que no se derrame una
sola gota de sangre ni se dispara en
cohetes por la muerte de su esposo un
pedido que choca con los mensajes de los
grupos palestinos naciscada islámica
Palestina prometió que Israel pagará el
precio y jamás que gobierna en casa
llamó a escalar la resistencia en tanto
que Israel elevó el nivel de alerta al
máximo en las cárceles por posibles
protestas